and you have well two more i guess one
more we'll talk about berserk after uh
beck
the manga for background i've only
watched the anime
you've only watched the anime
joey joey i'm showing my character
you
i mean dude i [ __ ] love the anime and
again same thing everyone's saying the
monger is even better the manga is even
yeah before you get your dicks out and
start comparing them what would you the
plot of back i know nothing
i mean it's it's like uh it's it's a
musical isn't it right [ __ ] off it's not
a musical it's amazing it's just music
yeah he just plays music he just joins a
band and tries to get big yeah so
come on [ __ ] off i'm not even joking i'm
sick i'm not joking that's really the
part of what's good about it then
it's just this it's just the journey
it's it's completely character-driven
you looked at me dead in the eyes and
you said it's the journey well it's just
like
some some really is the chance yeah yeah
it's it's the journey i mean
it is like it's
it's uh what i love about beck i mean
it's a very simple story in that sense
it's a completely character-driven story
where
it's about a boy who joins a band and
they're very underground they're trying
to make it big um and it's literally
just their journey of making it big
right and you know i mean you've seen
movies and [ __ ] you know
star is poor
a star is born yeah and obviously
there's i mean there's sabrina
miley cyrus hannah montana
the best of both worlds i'm sorry i
think about that but just like better
how dare you dismiss miley like that
a good good musical anime it the most is
it just relies on the characters it's
very heavily reliant on the characters
but like the way the characters are
written and just the how they like play
off each other and like all of the i
mean
a it's very realistic
which is already like a big plus for me
especially with like a character-driven
story like that but also it's just like
yeah i don't know it's just a really
good journey do you think i'd enjoy it
uh do you like rock music i enjoy rock
music i mean it's it's if if you are
like to me like mark zuckerberg
do you like human things yes i like
human things
i kind of realized i asked the person i
enjoyed no i do you enjoys the beeps and
the boobs do you like rock music i i do
enjoy rock music but i felt like the
pressure is on for some reason sorry go
ahead
yeah i mean it's what i love about beck
is that it's just oh it just captures
the you know the love for rock and you
know good old you know old classic rock
and roll
to the music right yeah so that's why i
watched the anime yeah that's what i
thought
i thought that as well right because i
was just like [ __ ] i kind of really want
to know what happens but i don't know if
i can get invested in a um in a [ __ ]
manga about music where
i don't i don't know if you know
anything about manga but uh you can't
really hear anything that's going on in
the market don't have audio yeah and
then i realized and then i realized the
[ __ ]
i kind of realized a super life hack uh
when reading beck right because what
because you know i i also watched the
anime that's what got me into reading
the manga
um and i realized that when they're
playing
in their concerts and it's like you can
literally just play whatever song you
[ __ ] love and you feel the [ __ ]
emotion [ __ ] brain expansion brains
sounds like a lot of work you know i
gotta go through my playlist brain
expansion i mean like you can do it if
you if you kind of like want if you want
to like really get invested and really
like put yourself into this rock concert
but what what's amazing about the manga
is that it somehow captures the energy
of a concert so [ __ ] well and like if
you've ever been to a gig and if you've
ever if you've ever like seen sorry
sorry thanks thank you connor thank you
now i'm sorry i'm so bored
i sneeze when i'm bored
connor when he listens to someone
talking about music
there's a certain like energy to seeing
your favorite bands live and i don't
know how the manga the manga which is a
medium where you can't hear anything it
captures the energy so well
that you can play the music of whatever
your favorite band is and you're just
like holy [ __ ] i'm feeling hyped and the
reason this
yeah yeah exactly and the the music is
just like
kind of like complimentary to that as
well
um and like if you like if you like the
anime joey then you're gonna [ __ ]
love the manga because the manga takes
the best parts of like the best scenes
of what happens in the anime and there
are there are scenes in the manga that
are like five times as hype as anything
that happens in grateful sounds i know
what i'm buying next and
sold yeah yeah and like it's it's hard
to sell back uh if you haven't seen the
anime because if if you haven't seen the
anime i think that's the best way to get
into the manga because it's like i said
it's a musical manga um and it might be
a hard sell if you don't know if if you
don't know what you're getting into but
if you like
but if you like rock uh if you feel like
good old rock and roll i still remember
that scene in beck that made me be like
hell yeah it was like the the scene
where he does the cover of i got a
feeling by the way yeah yeah that scene
is like the most [ __ ] like
hell yes
it is so good
i don't know what you're talking about
it's such a great it's such a cause it's
just so steeped in rock culture yeah
that's uh if you're if you like that
there's a lot there's a lot of people in
japan who just love [ __ ] rock and
people was like you know you see a
british like oh sex pistols yeah
yeah yeah that's that's a british
foreign
honestly like they make so many
references to like real-life bands which
is something i also love as well yeah
like they say like oh this person's
inspired by hendricks or sex pistols
there's another manga that does that oh
jojo yeah
exactly right
that was the joke i was gonna go for